>> Laura: GOVERNOR, THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
GREAT TO SEE YOU TONIGHT.
NOW ONTO THE BOMBSHELL LAWSUIT
THAT WAS JUST FILED BY
DEVIN NUNES AGAINST FUSION GPS
PEER THAT WAS THE FIRM BEHIND
THE STEELE DOSSIER.
EUNICE IS A LEADING THAT
FUSION GPS AND THE CAMPAIGN FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY WORKED ON A JOINT
AND SYSTEMATIC EFFORT TO
INTIMIDATE, HARASS, THREATEN,
INFLUENCE, INTERFERE, IMPEDE,
AND ULTIMATELY DERAIL HIS
INVESTIGATION INTO RUSSIA
ELECTION INTERFERENCE.
HERE NOW AS A CONGRESSMAN
HIMSELF, RANKING MEMBER OF THE
HOUSE UNTIL COMMITTEE.
CONGRESSMAN, NOW SOME PEOPLE WHO
HAVEN'T FOLLOWED EVERY ITERATION
OF THIS STORY, HOW TO READ
FUSION GPS TRY TO IMPEDE YOUR
INVESTIGATION?
>> WELL, ALL PEOPLE HAVE TO DO
IS GO BACK TO 2018 AND IF YOU
REMEMBER, THERE WERE DAILY
STORIES THAT WOULD BE GENERATED
ABOUT HOW HIGH THE LEAK SAID
BEN, I WASN'T UNDER
INVESTIGATION, I WAS OBSTRUCTING
AN INVESTIGATION, WELCOME OF
THOSE WERE ALL ORIGINATING FROM
THE ETHICS COMPLAINTS THEY
CONTINUE TO BE FILED BY CAMPAIGN
FOR ACCOUNTABILITY.
SO WHAT WE ENDED UP FINDING OUT
IS THAT OF THE $1.2 MILLION THAT
THEY RAISED IN 2018, $140,000
OVER 10% OF THE BUDGET, WENT TO
FUSION GPS.
TWO OF THE THREE ETHICS
COMPLAINTS DIRECTLY RELATED TO
FUSION GPS.
ONLY FUSION GPS COULDN'T HAVE
GIVEN THIS CAMPAIGN FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY.
MOST OF THE STRIKE, CAMPAIGN FOR
ACCOUNT ABILITY HAS BEEN AROUND
FOR OVER 40 YEARS.
THEY ARE A LEFT-WING
ORGANIZATION.
THEY ATTACK REPUBLICANS ON A
DAILY BASIS SO IF PEOPLE WANT TO
CLEAN UP POLITICS, ONLY THE
COURTS ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
DO THIS AND SO THAT'S WHY WE ARE
TAKING US TO THE THIRD BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT, THE COURT SYSTEM AND
WE ARE HOPEFUL THAT THE COURT
WILL COME IN AND SEE THAT AS A
RICOH A RACKETEERING GROUP.
>> Laura: THE LEFT DOES THIS
ALL THE TIME.
THEY RUN TO THE COURTS TO TRY TO
THWART THE PRESIDENT'S AGENDA.
THEY'VE DONE A NONAGENDA,
EMIGRATION, THE TRAVEL BAN,
THERE IS NOTHING THIS
ADMINISTRATION HAS TRIED TO DO
HAVE ANY SIGNIFICANT AT THE
LEFT HASN'T TRIED TO STOP IN A
COURTROOM.
SO I THINK IT'S GREAT THAT YOU
ARE OUT THERE AND YOU ARE TRYING
TO INSTILL SOME SENSE OF
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
INTO THIS WHOLE PROCESS.
I THINK MORE CONSERVATIVES
FRANKLY SHOULD DO WHAT YOU ARE
DOING AND I ALSO HAVE TO REPLAY
THIS MOMENT FROM THE MUELLER
HEARING THIS SUMMER WHERE HE
COULD NOT RECALL A VERY
IMPORTANT PIECE OF THE PUZZLE.
WATCH.
>> QUOTES THE FIRM THAT PRODUCED
FUEL RECORDINGS, THE NAME OF
THAT PERMIT WAS FUSION GPS.
IS THAT CORRECT?
>> YOU ARE ON PAGE ZERO THREE?
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
THE NAME OF THE FROM THE PRODUCE
US THAT WAS FUSION GPS, ZACH
ERTZ?
>> I'M NOT FAMILIAR WITH THAT.
>> IS NOT A TRICK QUESTION.
WAS IT FUSION GPS?
>> THAT WAS LIKE A JOB OUT AN
ANSWER ON THAT ONE.
WAS THAT?
>> ALL, THERE WERE A LOT OF
ANSWERS LIKE THAT.
CLEARLY >> Laura: END OF NOAH
WAS IN HIS OWN REPORT AND THAT'S
WHERE WE HAVE TO BRING THESE
LAWSUITS IS TO CLEAN UP THIS
MESS.
REMEMBER, FUSION GPS HAS A LONG
HISTORY OF DOING THIS.
THEY DID IT TO THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN, THEY DID IT TO BUILD
BROADER, PEOPLE FORGET THESE
GUYS WORKED FOR THE RUSSIANS.
THEY WORKED FOR DIRTY
VENEZUELANS AND DIRTY RUSSIANS
AND THIS IS A GROUP THAT HAS TO
STOP AND THE ONLY WAY IT CAN
STOP IS IF REPUBLICANS WHO ARE
IN A POSITION TO BE ABLE TO